[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs ça fait une semaine euh
qu'est-ce tu en a pensé de la coupe de
duugo toi honnêtement honnêtement tu
préfères cette semaine elle était
dégueulasseadore l'adore bravo chérie
bravo bravo c'est bien elle dit des
choses au moinè bien c'est trè bien euh
les chirritiens vous savez qui on a
parlé de Nantes et ben la mère de Nantes
nous a répondu euh sur les décoration de
Noël elle nous a répondu elle m'a même
invité à N d'ailleurs elle m'a même
invité à qu'est-ce qui se passe qu-ce
qu'il a rien elle a bien fait ah ouais
vous allez y aller ça va vous le moralah
oui vous allez y
aller vous avez changé depuis hier la
coupe de cheveux est pas pareil non mais
il a pris 5 ans en un
jour j'attendais le premier compliment
deémission il ce
soir mais tu as pris la
foudreou non je te j que tu es hyper
beau tu es hyper classe tu es de plus en
plus classe je te dis parfois on demande
si tu es un beau gosse comme ça comme ça
tu vois genre des beautés et ben la
première premier qui me vient l'esprit
c'est toi
touché non mais je te jure vraiment ah
là là sincère en plus il y a pas de
derrière mer je te jure non mais il a il
a tu vois il a une élégance une Prance
ouais non une élégance les deux j'ais
dire il a plus d'élégance qu'est-ce
qu'il y a non j'allais dire la même
chose que Géraldine que il a du charisme
quand il arrive tu le vois quoi quiine
oui c'est un compliment elle est pas
toujours
[Rires]
honnête franchement do être contente
d'être ton bras très contente non c'est
vrai ouais pour ça qu'elle y est
jamais on aime Noël et àant on fait le
Paris de la culture je le dis parce
qu'il y a là quelque chose qui se joue
qui est un problème y compris je le dis
jusqu'au bout un problème de déontologie
d'une partie de la presse nationale
quand une information sort sur ces news
qu'elle se retrouve chez Cyril Anouna
hier soir sans avoir été vérifié moi
j'attends j'attends ces messieurs à Nant
pour venir boire un vain chaud faire une
bise au Père Noël et puis prendre un
petit peu de culture aussi je crois que
ça leur fera pas de mal rig la mre de N
je l'adore c'est c'est la CPE mon frère
on l'a tous eu dans notre lycée il VI R
de culture pas culture pant moi je serai
tranquillement en vacances les no en
éventil sur une chaise longue il en a
qui vont jongler en fin d'année Anouna
et les autres là et qu'on sort
incroyable alors c'est quoi l'histoire
elle défend sa ville est-ce qu'elle dit
que vous savez que je vais sans charier
je vais je vais y aller ah ah ouais on y
va vas-y on y va je vais non j'ai d non
non j'ai pas dit on y va j'ai dit je
vais y aller arrêtez arrêtez de de de de
me coller au cul non mais juste pardon
non mais sans rigoler j'ai dit je vais y
aller il y a l'autre là qui arrive ouais
on va y aller mais tu veux Ken à tout
prix toi sans rigoler bah il y a une
raison vous avez dit que vous voilà vous
étiez un peu en jacher donc je mais non
mais non t'emmerdes pas avec ça je suis
très bien t'emmerdes pas avec ça
occupe-i de Patrick Bruel et non mais
pardonz qui a le Doig
ou nous dit qu'elle défend sa ville en
fait elle a pas défendu sa ville elle a
attaqué ses news et nous en disant qu'on
était des abroutis qu'on y connaissait
rien et qu'on avait propagé des fake
news pas tout fait la même
chose on a la chance d'avoir une
journaliste Pascal De La Tour du Pin
bonsir
bonsoir elle est belle je te dise brille
franchement dismoi tu dois avoir du
sucès ah bonès déjà
si tu
devais es obligé on déjàit le je j'ai
CIT tout le monde tu dois en choisir un
es obligé de PCH quelqu'un autour de la
tableêes ta famille elle
meorte je suis très déçu mais dis pas de
bêtis bah si moi c'était vous c'est
plébisc cé non calme-toi oublie-moi moi
c'est bon le problème comme
ça c'est bon Arte avec
moion arrêtez
là les
autres mais c'est bon voilàas t ce'emde
pas non mais c'est vrai alors oui alors
qui bah si tu
veux qu'est-ce qu'il a dit mar il rigole
ce bâtard hein il est là parce que j'ai
l'impression que le réisateur c'est pas
qui est moard c'est lui tu rigoles
toi ta gueule ta
gueule a une histoire il y a aucune
histoire c'est voilà il a dit qu'il
avait une histoire il y a aucune
histoire c'est mon pote il con rien une
blague mais toi tu comprends rien c'est
juste choisi quelqu'un
oh ça c'est pas possible je pense que
c'est Hugo bon Hugo
ça dire il est déjà pris non non je peux
pas taper toutes les meufs du plateau he
non mais c'est VI tu t'es déjà tapé une
meuf bah oui bien sûrou ah bah oui
plusieurs même ah ou ou ou avit pas de
couille he ouou non elle n'avait pas
[Applaudissements]
de s rigoler on a tous ce gars là dans
notre famille ouais c'est vrai en plus
c'est le CL relou tu l'as quoi qu'il
arrive dans ta famille c'est lui c'est
ce garsl on l'aime non mais al non non
tu P ch combien de meuf peut-être 5 si
Ahou quand même ou ou ouais plus que G
alors qu'il é plus que alors qu'il
é dans sa chaî tu t'es déjà tapé des
mecs ou pas Gill non non je devrais
essayer Gill pourquoi je devrais
essayer t peut-être pour la voix aussi
peut-être non mais je sais pas
débloquerai je sais pas non non non mais
je c'était avant mes 25 ans c'était
vraiment quand tu découvres un peu ta
sexualité alors tu as pas kiffé tu as
pas kiffé euh j'ai pas tu as peut-être
pas connu les bonnes je pense qu'il faud
une fois c'était pas mal quand même ouis
une fois c'était pas mal pas ouf mais
pas ouf et je me demande si un jour je
le referaai ou pas avec une femme non ça
trouve he ah ouais ouais si la si
Laurent nous regarde ça lui faire
plaisir ah non mais je vais encore vivre
longtemps potentiellement je peux avoir
tu es en train de dire tu es en train de
dire que Laurent va pas
dire mais non on sait pas on sait pas ce
que
l'avenir ce soir c'est sûr tu ces pas ce
so ce soir c'est la
merde ce soir
c'estour en tout cas j' mais c'est
l'expression française l'Auberge du cul
tourn c'est lourd allez sors
[Applaudissements]
sors s en tout cas juste pour finir C
j'aurais adoré être htro parce que je
sais que je me serais tapé un nombre de
meufs et ça aurait été ma vie aurait été
tellement plus simple bah tu peux
changer d'Ave hein bah non on peut pas
parce que malheureusement je choisis pas
vraiment sa sexualité ouais c'est c'est
ce que disait Maxime forest Maxim for
dis pas ses parents chois pas j'aurais
été un super htéro quoi j'aurais été un
super htéro je me serais tapé les plus
belles meufs de lais c'est vrai ah ouais
ouais avec qui tu serais sorti là ici
euh bah
pour faire des soirées non mais non mais
non je te parle non pour faire des
soirées en coéquipier en coéquipier ah
bah Jean
Moon Jean Moon et rmon pense qu'il
doivent être bon délire non c'est pas
mal on peut aller dans un petit club g
si vous voulez ensemble moi ça non vous
avez déjà est-ce que vous avez déjà été
vous avez déjà été dans un
clou je pas all Ann ah ou pas prê je va
attend 2024 je pas encore prê et ben
janvier 2024 on y va ensemble non
mais tout de suite 204
c'esten Mo aussi au Queen
Rapp
di dans C CASL vous êtes déjà
dans souvz
maisra S vu trouve on s Bou
non non t'emmerd pas t'emmerdes pas
allez sur 100
personnes combien et vous PZ pas dire un
truc vous en fait sur la mer de nente
qu'est-ce que devis
dire demand des preuves
av vous êtes comment au niveau de la
mémoire je pas jeux
dire je pe me poser des questions dit
qu'on dit des fake news des informou
donc je vois pas pourquoi ce sont ce
sont des fake news c'est à elle de
justifier c'est pas à nous bien sûr vous
voulez venir avec moi voulez venir avec
moi à Nant bah non on parle mais oui bah
oui on vient on y va on va à Nant quand
vous voulez non mais on va y aller sans
rigoler on va aller Mo j'aur la
journaliste avec moi on y va tout les
non mais d'où on sort des fake news on y
va t les la M de voà c'est fait la mère
de Nant elle dit que les fake news parce
que moi j'ai eu aussi des gens qui m'ont
dit qu'il y avait des rues piéton n où
il y avait des sapins de Noël où ils
allent faire des Noë qui avait des Noël
et nous ce qu'on a montré c'est un truc
qui est complètement différent de la
fête de Noël c'est deux deux événements
différents
P pas new
ENIT